talking of course about the i-515 and
the 95. northbound down to one lane at
eastern until six about another 20
minutes or so our bianco holmen is right
there where all this is happening
because bianca some folks are going to
claim that they were surprised by all
this we're trying to make sure they know
about it
oh most definitely nate we're telling
them every morning no excuses so this is
an area where it's going to be a major
cone zone so heads up that some good
news is at the southbound las vegas
boulevard on ramp and southbound eastern
off ramps are open but heads up they're
going to be closed tomorrow starting at
11
at night now heads up for some updates
this weekend eastern avenue where we are
right now will be closed to drivers and
pedestrians under the 5 15. this starts
sunday night at 10 p.m and it lasts
until wednesday the 13th the closure is
to protect folks while the ndot performs
the demolition of the south section of
the i-5515
bridge and now the second phase of the
demolition that's not going to take
place until next year again they're kind
of taking this project in phases because
again it's a high
traveled area reporting live bianca
holman live local now